combien de kilomètres donc là je vois
qu'il y a 1 2 3 ou allez 4,5 km très
bien 4,5 km de parcours pour découvrir
le domaine Fleurier dans le secteur de
la montagne une visite guidée gratuite
dans le cadre des weekends nature action
pour la préservation des espaces
naturels sensibles mis en place par le
département
alors sur le domaine florier espace
naturel sensible du département donc les
gens ils vont découvrir un paysage qui
est qui est particulier donc qui fait
qui fait balcon sur sur l'océan et quand
on longe la la rive droite de la ravine
de la Grande Chaloupe on peut découvrir
le chemin des Anglais autre espace
naturel sensible plus l'océan donc c'est
une vue qui est qui est quand même qui
est pas mal à ce niveaaulà les
promeneurs ont pu découvrir des espèces
indigène et endémique de la forêt
semi-sèche une balade ludique et
conviviale où chacun J détective en
découvrant des espèces parfois inconnues
ben c'était pour découvrir un peu plus
mon quartier quoi comme je viens souvent
ici ben c'est
pour voir un peu plus ce qui ce qui se
fait dans le détail quoi parce que
souvent on passe devant on connait on
dit on connaît mais avec la présence
d'un professionnel on peut apprendre
plus de choses quoi je pense mais tout
simplement pour découvrir notre île pour
découvrir des coins qu'on ne connaît pas
qu'on croit connaître mais finalement on
voit qu'il y a beaucoup de choses qu'on
ne connaît pas encore découvrir la
nature et puis communiquer avec les
autres le dire malisy faites des des
sorties vous allez voir c'est
enrichissant et puis c'est toujours bon
de connaître de découvrir pour découvrir
un petit peu plus notre île et pour
voilà pour savoir un petit peu plus
découvrir des choses apprendre des
choses comme vous venez de dire et puis
recommencer peut-être d'autres journées
semblables les weekends nature une belle
opportunité pour le public de visualiser
toutes les activités conservatoires
faites sur les espaces naturels
sensibles